please welcome sutton foster
[Applause]
okay
thank you so much for being here and i'm
so excited to talk to you today about
your book
um
this is going to be huge this is going
to be a giant new york times
best-selling phenomenon
it's um
it's ironic that it's called hooked
because it
you you open it
and i read it all in one sitting
i could not put it down
did you know it was going to be that
gripping when you wrote it no i'm
thrilled that it was i i
i i don't i didn't know i just knew that
i i felt like i had a story that i
wanted to tell and
um
and i knew that i wanted to tell it
through the lens of things that i i had
made um it it's uh it's a memoir it's a
memoir it's my life it's it's how i've
got to be the person i am today
but each chapter is framed around um
something that i've made with my hands
like whether it's a blanket i made when
i was going through my divorce or
waiting to adopt my daughter or the
cookies that i made with my ex-husband's
mom so
this is actually there's a chapter about
about this in the book this is my
ex-husband's mom's christmas cookie
recipe and i make it every year it's
mama borals christmas cookies and so
it's just the book is about too it's
like you know you can take different
life ingredients
and you can create your own recipe and
it's it provides a window into telling
into storytelling that um that felt very
authentic to me
and
it's ironic you call it crafting
um i told you this the last time we were
you were here
sutton your stuff is not crafting it's
like
museum level works of art i mean
speaking of of things that i've made i
actually made you something it's
officially the holiday season so here
you go
[Applause]
oh sutton
[Applause]
oh my god it's a it's a toilet paper
roll cover oh my god
[Applause]
i can't believe i have a sutton foster
original
um okay
i it's hard
to
even sum up how beautiful your book is
um i loved the way that you spoke about
your relationship with your mother which
is a very
important subject for me what would you
like people to know going into the book
to reading about you and your mom
my mom was a
she was a challenging figure in my life
my mother was
she had undiagnosed mental illness so
that was
that was what that was my normal
ultimately we
believe she she had agoraphobia she was
afraid of the world and and felt like
the world was against her
um interesting and interestingly enough
my brother and i are both uh broadway
performers and like live a very uh turn
off yeah existence
um
but i think
what
i'm most proud of with the book is that
i was able to
i mean i've worked so hard in my life to
to accept my mother and accept her
limitations um i always i have this
acceptance without expectation but one
of the thing one of the gifts i think in
writing the book for me was that
i had focused so many years on her um
limitations and also her
and my frustrations and my
disappointments
but but in writing the book i found her
strengths
i i found enormous gratitude for her for
what she she gave to me
what
and and how much pain that she was she
was in um so it was incredibly cathartic
for me now i feel like i got to my 40s i
had two kids i was like oh the baggage
with me and my mom it is gone i've
worked through it i have nothing but
gratitude i can see her positives
however i swore that i would not be the
same kind of parent she was and
truthfully i honestly found myself
finding some similarities
and did you find that too of course like
you're i'll never be like my mom oh my
god i'm like my mom yeah i know i always
said the same thing i was like i will
i'm gonna do it all completely different
but then you're just inherently it's
part of your dna i mean one of the
things that helps me stay balanced
honestly is is crocheting is crafting is
something that can be incredibly
internal and very small and i i end up
giving a lot to the world right i'm in
rehearsals right now for the music man
oh
um
it's funny because
i can't wait to see that show
it's been a long time coming we've been
waiting for over two years it's unbelie
it's unbelievable i cannot wait for you
to see it we're all so excited i'm so
excited it's the hottest ticket in town
i mean you have no idea i'm such a fan
of your work and i loved the story
um when you get into
going into the journey of becoming a mom
it's a few chapters no that's my
daughter
that's a real picture yeah
no i did so i i when i started my
journey into motherhood it was later in
life and we we hit many struggles um
went through several rounds of ivf and
finally ended up pursuing adoption and
uh
and that as soon as we started pursuing
adoption it's when all the
roadblocks and obstacles kind of got out
of our way
and um
yeah i have a beautiful four and a half
year old daughter
emily yeah she's the best
she's the best and you know what is so
much fun
the best part the best part is that i
get to now share all of this stuff with
her so like we she's like mommy
let's go do a craft and i'm like yes
i'm like my dreams are coming true you
know
[Music]
you